pierre lucien aimé blanc
vous affirmez dans votre livre robert
broussard ne pouvait pas être témoin de
la fusillade et des circonstances qui
l'ont provoqué car il était à ce moment
précis assis à côté de moi dans sa
voiture garée à 50 mètres de là est hors
de vue de la scène
c'est grâce à ben non je confirme
complètement
nous étions dans la voiture du
commandement depuis le matin en été en
dans le périphérique un peu plus loin à
200 mètres de l'immeuble puis lorsque le
dispositif s'est mis en branle le 13 07
rhéologiques marc broussard et est au
volant - passagers puis avec
l'inspecteur derrière c'est cette
avancée dans la porte de clignancourt
car il avait donné des instructions pour
que la voiture de de mesrine ne dépasse
pas le feu rouge il était hors de
question d'aller allait le suivre sur le
périphérique on savait pas où ils
allaient puis l'opération était embêté
trouve au trop aléatoire donc on s'est
avancé sous la rampe au niveau de la
place jean encore une cinquantaine
cinquantaine de mètres à peu près on
voyait rien et à ce moment là la radio
le camion a fait savoir à monsieur
broussard qu'il était en place et que la
bm de mesrine était derrière
alors il a donné l'ordre d'intervention
il a dit intervenez les gens intervenez
les gars vous allez j ai légal
enfin il a donné lors des interventions
à ce moment là les rafales rus kat et
durera pas le sech courtes dont il
venait de sortir de la voiture et s'est
précipité sur la porte de clignancourt
pour rejoindre ses effectifs et mesrine
était mort puisqu'il y avait pas il n'y
a pas eu de riposte au coup par coup
y a pas eu de bruit de grenade puisque
vous savez qu'il avait des grenades dans
la voiture et moi je me suis gelé suivi
tout à fait tranquillement je dois
avouer je savais que c'était fini je me
suis pas précipité c'était lui qui était
responsable de ce dispositif
donc ce que vous affirmez aujourd'hui
lucien aimé blanc sait que le
commissaire broussard ne peut pas savoir
si des sommations ont été faites pas
plus que moyen mesrine a essayé
d'attraper des grenades offensives qui
était à l'inter de sa portière ou sous
son siège tout ce qu'il raconte c'est
pour couvrir ces mecs là je pense parce
que écouter un moment donné on était
dans la voiture il n'est pas sorti de la
voiture de commandement
et puis dans ses mémoires j'ai vu que un
moment donné au moment de la fusillade
finale et il se mettait dans une
camionnette aménagée et je sais pas où
était cette camionnette mails gmail
avait fallu qu'ils ont débuté et se
taper mois point final je le confirme
et puis c'est très bien que je dis la
vérité on va lui
on a enfin enfin une version à peu près
claire de ce qui s'est passé le 2
novembre 1979 à 15h15 à la porte de
clignancourt et on comprend évidemment
que le commissaire broussard a dit ça
pour couvrir ses troupes
ils nous attaquent un jeu son bois non
non
dans sa parole contre la nôtre où et
depuis je lui en veux pas moi je
respecte bruxelles reconnaît ses
qualités
oui je crois qu'il croit d'ailleurs que
quand il a décidé de porter plainte en
diffamation
et il a lu l'article de libération qui
était le commissaire aimé blanc déclare
que les fonctionnaires de police d'avery
en tirer sans sommation un mois je ne
dis pas qu'ils ont tiré sans sommation
jeudi qu'il était avec moi donc il faut
même pas plus que moi entendre les
solutions maintenant est-ce que les
sommations été faite peut-être que des
fêtes